so it's really great for startups for
getting started with google analytics
there's a default implementation that
allows them to get started really
quickly and easily with some key
features that they'll get to get right
off the bat the first one is the number
of users and sessions the second is
session duration they can know their
operating systems the device models and
geography so right off the bat they
don't they do much because they get that
information right off when they set it
up after that that's when they can go
even more deeper to get some more
details about users things like who are
more likely to buy in-app purchases
people who are stopping at a certain
level for a game specific app or if
someone who just drops off and hasn't
used the app in a long time